This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In September 1958, Bank of America decided to try an experiment, one that would have far reaching effects on our lives and on the economy. They decided after careful consideration to conduct this experiment in Fresno, California. The thinking was, no one was paying much attention to Fresno, so if the plan failed, it wouldn't get a lot of media attention. Things were slow back then here. Fresno was not the big metropolitan area it is today. That's Joseph Rusek. My name is Joseph Rusek. I've worked with Bank of America since 1956 and retired in 1985. Started off as a teller. I worked our way up, and most of us young fellows did.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。1958年9月，美国银行决定进行一项实验，这项实验将对我们的生活和经济产生深远的影响。经过慎重考虑，他们决定在加利福尼亚州的弗雷斯诺进行这项实验。当时的想法是，没人会太关注弗雷斯诺，所以如果计划失败，也不会引起太多的媒体关注。那时这里的生活节奏很慢。弗雷斯诺不像今天这样是一个大都市区。那是约瑟夫·鲁塞克。我叫约瑟夫·鲁塞克。我从1956年开始在美国银行工作，1985年退休。起初我是一名出纳员。我们一步步晋升，我们大多数年轻人都是这样。
Joseph was there when all this went down. And so in September of 1958, Bank of America sent out 60,000 pieces of mail to people in Fresno. Inside, with a little plastic object, that has become an equal parts, emblematic of opportunity, convenience, and debt. He's talking about the credit card. That's reporter Nate Berg here to tell you what I'm talking about.
约瑟夫亲历了这一切。因此，在1958年9月，美国银行向弗雷斯诺的居民寄出了6万封邮件。里面有一个小塑料物件，它已成为机会、便利和债务的象征。他指的是信用卡。那是记者内特·伯格，他来告诉你我所说的是什么。
Bank of America had recruited about 300 merchants in Fresno to accept this new payment system, and they'd asked employees like Joseph to hand credit cards out to people they knew. We did, we passed around our friends, you know, the neighbors, that's about it. out to people they knew. But as for Joseph, he was skeptical about using a credit card himself. I can credit myself. Why not? Well, you have to pay back interest, and I don't like giving money away. Joseph wasn't alone. The whole town of Fresno was a bit nervous about this new credit card system.
美国银行在弗雷斯诺招募了大约300家商户来接受这种新的支付系统，并要求像约瑟夫这样的员工将信用卡分发给他们认识的人。我们确实这样做了，我们把卡分给了朋友、邻居，差不多就是这样。但至于约瑟夫，他自己对使用信用卡持怀疑态度。我可以自己记账。为什么不呢？嗯，你必须偿还利息，我不喜欢白白送钱。约瑟夫并不孤单。整个弗雷斯诺镇对这个新的信用卡系统都感到有些不安。
The concept of credit wasn't new, but it had never been done quite like this. Going back into, say, the 1800s, early 1900s, few had credit with a store or some kind of a business It was just kind of a ledger book type of thing This is Ken Howenbeck. He's a new Mismatist a new Mismatist That is someone who studies or collects currency not just coins, but it's paper money metals tokens Anything that's some money or money substitute Ken is retired now, but its paper money, metals, tokens, anything that's some money
信贷的概念并不新鲜，但从未以这种方式进行过。追溯到19世纪或20世纪初，很少有人在商店或某种企业拥有信贷额度。那只是一种账本记录。这是肯·豪恩贝克。他是一位钱币学家。钱币学家是指研究或收集货币的人，不仅仅是硬币，还包括纸币、金属、代币，任何属于货币或货币替代品的东西。肯现在退休了，但他是纸币、金属、代币，任何属于货币的东西
or money substitute. Ken is retired now, but he used to work at the American New Mismatic Association. New Mismatic. So back in the late 1800s, every place from the corner bar to the local pharmacy allowed patrons to keep open tabs. They'd record everything in a ledger book and allow their customers to charge up a bill that they'd typically pay back at the end of the month. For businesses, this was an accounting nightmare. Stores could have hundreds of accounts, billing tabs for a dollar here and a dollar there,
或货币替代品。肯现在退休了，但他过去在美国钱币协会工作。钱币学。所以早在19世纪末，从街角的酒吧到当地的药店，每个地方都允许顾客挂账。他们会把一切记录在账本上，并允许顾客记账，通常在月底结清。对于企业来说，这是一场会计噩梦。商店可能有数百个账户，这里记一美元，那里记一美元，
and with each chart, a shopkeeper would have to haul out a ledger book and look up a customer's records just to complete a transaction. Eventually, store owners cut down on some of the paperwork by assigning customers account numbers, which they would inscribe on little tokens. Most of them were round, or oval, and I'm going to have a number on them, and that was your account number. Ken has a collection of a few dozen of these old credit tokens, many dating back to the early 20th century. I have one here, it says Pocahontas, Pioneer, Garage, but it has a head of an
每记一笔账，店主就得搬出账本，查阅顾客的记录才能完成交易。最终，店主通过为顾客分配账号来减少文书工作，并将账号刻在小代币上。它们大多是圆形的或椭圆形的，上面有一个数字，那就是你的账号。肯收藏了几十个这种旧的信贷代币，许多可以追溯到20世纪初。我这里有一个，上面写着波卡洪塔斯、先锋、车库，但它上面有一个印第安人的头像，
Indian on it, and on the back it has a number 839. After credit tokens came something called Charger Plates, they look like little dog tags for the army. They were metal and had your name and information imprinted on them. Shopkeepers could make an impression of your personal information directly onto the bill, instead of having to write it all down. But the more accounts you had, the more charge-a-plates and tokens you had to carry around with you. It still wasn't a great system for the retailer or the customer. So in 1949, a New York businessman named Frank X McNamara came up with an idea for a single charge card that could be accepted at multiple establishments. He called it the Diner's Club Card,
背面有一个数字839。在信贷代币之后出现了一种叫做“充电板”的东西，它们看起来像军队的狗牌。它们是金属制的，上面印有你的名字和信息。店主可以直接将你的个人信息压印在账单上，而不必全部手写。但是你拥有的账户越多，你需要随身携带的充电板和代币就越多。对于零售商或顾客来说，这仍然不是一个好的系统。因此，在1949年，一位名叫弗兰克·X·麦克纳马拉的纽约商人想出了一个主意，即一张可以在多家机构接受的单一收费卡。他称之为大来卡，
and with it you could make charges at a number of New York restaurants and hotels. But unlike the credit card of today, you could only use your diner's club card in certain places. The idea caught on somewhat. About 20,000 people signed up, mostly businessmen. It wasn't a smash success, but still the banks started to see an opportunity. So you have this giant change taking place right around World War II and especially in the aftermath of World War II when the American economy was basically the only economy in the world that was still standing. That's Joe Noceira, colonist for the New York Times and author of a piece of the action,
你可以用它在多家纽约餐厅和酒店消费。但与今天的信用卡不同，你只能在特定的地方使用大来卡。这个想法在一定程度上流行起来。大约有2万人注册，主要是商人。它并没有取得巨大的成功，但银行开始看到机会。所以，在第二次世界大战前后，特别是在二战之后，美国经济基本上是世界上唯一还在运转的经济体，发生了巨大的变化。那是乔·诺塞拉，《纽约时报》的专栏作家，《行动的一部分》一书的作者，
how the middle class joined the money class. People having gotten through the war, settling down, getting married, raising kids, wanting to live in the suburbs, there were suddenly things they wanted to buy, a refrigerator, for example, or as it came into volga television. So maybe you'd have a Sears account. You could buy things there and pay your bill at the end of the month. But if you didn't have an account with a store, you'd have to go to a bank and get a traditional loan for any relatively large purchase. Whether it was a car, whether it was a sofa, whether it was a refrigerator, you'd go to the bank every single time, every single time.
讲述了中产阶级如何加入金钱阶层。人们度过了战争，安定下来，结婚，养育孩子，想要住在郊区，突然间有了他们想买的东西，比如冰箱，或者后来流行的电视机。所以也许你会有一个西尔斯账户。你可以在那里买东西，并在月底支付账单。但如果你在商店没有账户，你必须去银行申请传统的贷款来购买任何相对较大的商品。无论是汽车、沙发还是冰箱，你每次都要去银行，每次都要去。
You know, you had to have collateral to pay for it. Every single time the banker would have to figure out whether you were a good credit risk. It was a pretty cumbersome process, both for the consumer and for the bank. Bank of America wanted to find an easier way to make these small loans. Bank of America was, in the 1950s,
你知道，你必须有抵押品来支付它。银行家每次都必须弄清楚你是否是一个好的信贷风险。对于消费者和银行来说，这都是一个相当繁琐的过程。美国银行想找到一种更简单的方法来发放这些小额贷款。美国银行在20世纪50年代是
the premier consumer-oriented bank in the United States. Bank of America really believed in the idea that it would grow by helping consumers. So it was Bank of America that decided that they would basically give clients a card that they could put in their pockets, that would give them roughly a $500 line of credit. Unlike the diner's club, Bank of America wanted their customers to be able to use their card anywhere, not just at restaurants. And where the diners club had to be paid off within 60 days, Bank of America would allow its customers to pay them back whenever they wanted. They'd call their new credit card, the Bank of America. You could spend it all down, you could pay part of it back,
美国首屈一指的面向消费者的银行。美国银行确实相信通过帮助消费者来发展壮大的理念。因此，美国银行决定基本上给客户一张可以放进口袋的卡，给他们大约500美元的信贷额度。与大来卡不同，美国银行希望他们的客户能够在任何地方使用他们的卡，而不仅仅是在餐厅。大来卡必须在60天内还清，而美国银行允许客户在他们想要的任何时候还款。他们把这种新信用卡称为美国银行卡。你可以全部花掉，也可以偿还一部分，
you could pay it all back. You didn't have to get a banker to approve your purchase, and you didn't have to pay the bank back by any specific time. They called this revolving credit. The card was essentially an instant loan. Of course, it was a loan with an interest rate attached. This was one of the profound shifts in the way people handle money instead of it, the banker being in control of your money, of setting the terms for how you dealt with your money. With a credit card, you are the one setting the terms and you are the one making the decisions about what
你可以全部还清。你不必让银行家批准你的购买，也不必在任何特定时间偿还银行。他们称之为循环信贷。这张卡本质上是一笔即时贷款。当然，这是一笔附带利息的贷款。这是人们处理金钱方式的深刻转变之一，而不是银行家控制你的钱，设定你处理金钱的条款。有了信用卡，你就是设定条款的人，你就是决定如何处理你金钱的人。
to do with your money. Now all Bank of America had to do was convince retailers to accept credit cards as payment and convince people to use them. Now because they were a new invention and because people didn't really know what they were and because they were no laws surrounding credit cards, the way they tested the card was they simply sent a mailing to basically every Bank of America customer in Fresno, California, which brings us back to Fresno. They called it the Fresno Drop. Bank of America mailed out 60,000 credit cards all over the
现在，美国银行所要做的就是说服零售商接受信用卡作为支付方式，并说服人们使用它们。因为它们是一项新发明，因为人们并不真正知道它们是什么，而且因为当时没有关于信用卡的法律，他们测试卡片的方式就是简单地向加利福尼亚州弗雷斯诺的每一位美国银行客户寄送邮件，这让我们回到了弗雷斯诺。他们称之为“弗雷斯诺投放”。美国银行在全城寄出了6万张信用卡。
city. Fresno had become a laboratory for the future of personal finance. The Fresno Drop was supposed to be a controlled experiment where the bank could test the concept and work out any kinks. But within just a few months of the Fresno credit card drop, Bank of America got word that one of its competitors in California was planning a similar program. So Bank of America quickly expanded. Mass millions went out in the central valley cities of Modesto
弗雷斯诺已成为个人理财未来的实验室。弗雷斯诺投放本应是一项受控实验，银行可以在此测试概念并解决任何问题。但在弗雷斯诺信用卡投放后的几个月内，美国银行获悉其在加利福尼亚的一家竞争对手正在计划类似的计划。因此，美国银行迅速扩张。数百万张卡片被寄往中央谷地的莫德斯托
and Bakersfield, and then eventually to the state's bigger cities of Sacramento, San Francisco, and Los Angeles. Within 10 months of the Fresno drop, more than a million bank americarts have been mailed out across California. Once the cards had begun saturating the bigger cities, fraud and theft were rampant. People would go around to mailboxes and suburbs and steal cards on days when they knew the cards were being dropped. The system was being abused,
和贝克斯菲尔德，最终扩展到该州更大的城市萨克拉门托、旧金山和洛杉矶。在弗雷斯诺投放后的10个月内，超过一百万张美国银行卡已在加利福尼亚州寄出。一旦卡片开始覆盖大城市，欺诈和盗窃就猖獗起来。人们会在卡片投放的日子里去郊区的邮箱偷卡。系统被滥用了，
but the system was also randomly mailing out pre-approved credit cards that allowed anyone to buy up to $500 of whatever they wanted. You know, dead people were getting cards, dogs were getting cards. It was just very, very willing, nearly. Despite these mass mailings, the cards didn't catch on right away. It was hard to convince stores to accept them. They had to pay a percentage of the sale to the bank,
但该系统也随机寄出了预先批准的信用卡，允许任何人购买高达500美元的任何他们想要的东西。你知道，死人收到了卡，狗也收到了卡。这简直太随意了。尽管进行了大规模邮寄，但这些卡并没有立即流行起来。说服商店接受它们很困难。他们必须向银行支付销售额的一定比例，
and it was hard to get customers to use them. And when people did start using the cards, they didn't always pay the money back, which was a bit of a surprise to Bank of America. People had mostly been pretty good about paying back traditional loans. And what they forgot was, in those days when you made a loan, the customer looked the banker in the eye and the banker looked the customer in the eye and they both had this kind of relationship and the customer would not want to let the banker down.
而且很难让顾客使用它们。当人们开始使用这些卡时，他们并不总是偿还这笔钱，这让美国银行感到有些惊讶。人们在偿还传统贷款方面大多表现良好。他们忘记的是，在那些日子里，当你发放贷款时，顾客会看着银行家的眼睛，银行家也会看着顾客的眼睛，他们之间有这种关系，顾客不想让银行家失望。
Whereas with a credit card, it was an anonymous thing. And this anonymity meant one in four people weren't paying their credit card debts. In 1959, about a year after Bank of America did their first mass million in Fresno, they had mailed out more than two million bank of Americans, but they hadn't made a single set from their experiment.
而信用卡则是一种匿名的事情。这种匿名性意味着四分之一的人没有偿还信用卡债务。1959年，也就是美国银行在弗雷斯诺进行第一次大规模邮寄大约一年后，他们已经寄出了超过两百万张美国银行卡，但他们的实验并没有赚到一分钱。
In fact, they lost about $20 million. And so the bank started making a few changes. They really started to think about it differently. Bank of America set up a collections department and an anti-fraud unit. People who weren't paying their bills had their cards revoked. And the government also started to regulate
事实上，他们损失了大约2000万美元。于是银行开始做出一些改变。他们开始以不同的方式思考。美国银行成立了催收部门和反欺诈部门。不还账的人卡片被吊销。政府也开始监管
the credit card industry. In 1968, the Truth and Lending Act made it illegal to mail out credit cards to people who never asked for one. From that point onward, instead of getting a card in the mail, you got instead a solicitation to apply for a card, which in one form or another exists to this day. It wasn't until 1961, three years after the Fresno drop, that Bank of America actually turned a profit on their crazy credit card experiment. By 1968, they were making about $13 million a year. The Bank of America system, which became a nationwide system, eventually became known as Visa.
信用卡行业。1968年，《诚实信贷法》规定，向从未申请过的人邮寄信用卡是非法的。从那时起，你收到的不再是邮寄来的卡，而是申请卡的邀请，这种形式一直延续至今。直到1961年，也就是弗雷斯诺投放三年后，美国银行才真正从他们疯狂的信用卡实验中获利。到1968年，他们每年赚取约1300万美元。美国银行系统最终演变成全国性系统，后来被称为Visa。
And the other cards that had competed with Bank of America, they also consolidated and they became MasterCard. The major credit card companies now make lots and lots and lots of money every year, which is great for them. Maybe not so great for the rest of us. Today, over 70% of American adults have at least one credit card,
而其他与美国银行竞争的卡片也进行了合并，成为了万事达卡。主要的信用卡公司现在每年赚取大量的钱，这对他们来说很好。对我们其他人来说可能就不那么好了。今天，超过70%的美国成年人至少拥有一张信用卡，
and the US as a whole has about $900 billion in credit card debt. In 2009, more credit card reform was passed. It prevents arbitrary interest hikes, stops credit card companies from specifically marketing to college kids, prohibits certain types of abusive fees, but a lot of people think more reform is needed. The experiment in Fresno created a tool that made buying things much, much easier. You no longer had to put on a suit and a tie and go to the bank for a loan every time you
美国整体拥有约9000亿美元的信用卡债务。2009年，通过了更多的信用卡改革。它防止了任意加息，阻止信用卡公司专门向大学生推销，禁止某些类型的滥收费，但许多人认为需要更多的改革。弗雷斯诺的实验创造了一种让购物变得容易得多的工具。你不再需要每次都穿上西装打领带去银行申请贷款，
wanted to get yourself something nice. The credit card facilitated an unprecedented amount of economic freedom for the middle class, and that aspect was intentional and maybe even noble. But it's important to keep in mind that first and foremost, the credit card was designed to make money for banks and everything about their design betrays that primary objective. Credit cards don't have to be complicated. They don't have to trick you, but they do, because they were designed that way. My bills are all due and the babies need shoes, but I'm busted. Cotton is down to a quarter of pound and I'm busted.
想要买点好东西。信用卡为中产阶级带来了前所未有的经济自由，这一方面是故意的，甚至可能是高尚的。但重要的是要记住，信用卡首先是为了让银行赚钱而设计的，它们设计的方方面面都背叛了这一主要目标。信用卡不必复杂。它们不必欺骗你，但它们确实这样做了，因为它们就是那样设计的。我的账单都到期了，孩子们需要鞋子，但我破产了。棉花价格跌至每磅25美分，我破产了。
I got a cow that went to try and I can't that won't lay. A big stack of bills that get bigger each day. The county will hold my belong in so way. I'm busted. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Nate Berg with Katie Mingle, Avery Trophman, St. Greenspan, Kurt Colstead, and me Roman Mars. The new kids at 99PI starting today are Delaney Hall and Sherry Fusef. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of
我有一头牛要试着去挤奶，但我不能，它不下蛋。一大堆账单每天都在增加。县政府要扣押我的财产。我破产了。《99%隐形》本周由内特·伯格制作，凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特罗夫曼、圣·格林斯潘、库尔特·科尔斯塔德和我罗曼·马斯参与。从今天开始，《99PI》的新成员是德莱尼·霍尔和雪莉·福塞夫。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，制作于
the offices of Arxon, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram and Spotify and we are fascinating on every platform. But the easiest way to get more information on every single episode of 99% Invisible is at 99pion.org. Radio Tapio. From P-R-X. Tokyo. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Arxon建筑与室内设计公司办公室。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，我们在每个平台上都很迷人。但获取《99%隐形》每一集更多信息的最简单方法是访问99pion.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。东京。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。